veamos si podemos usar nuestro concepto
que ya aprendimos sobre las estructuras
de enlace línea para mostrar un poco más
sobre la digamos las tres dimensiones
que tienen nuestras moléculas así que
vamos a empezar con uno realmente
sencillo vamos a empezar con el propano
que ya vimos en el ejemplo anterior y de
hecho lo que ya hemos visto o que de
hecho ya a lo mejor ya conocemos
bastante bien es que este tiene tres
átomos de carbono que es cada uno de
estos vértices en esta estructura de
línea ok entonces tenemos tres carbonos
3 carbonos que están conectados
de esta forma verdad y en esta
estructura está implícito todos los
hidrógenos que están conectados a estos
carbonos entonces en este por ejemplo en
este primer carbono que corresponde a
este de aquí tenemos otros 3 hidrógenos
porque el carbono necesita 4 enlaces
entonces tenemos otros 3 hidrógenos este
carbono de aquí ya tiene dos enlaces así
que simplemente le corresponde estar
unido a otros
hidrógenos y éste último carbono está
unido a otros tres hidrógenos muy bien
entonces lo que sabemos de esta
estructura o de estos carbonos es que
cada uno de ellos tienen una hibridación
sp3 y cuando tienen esta hibridación sp3
les corresponde un arreglo en forma de
tetraedro entonces como podríamos
representar un poco más de esta molécula
o como podríamos representar esta
estructura tridimensional de esta
molécula entonces lo que los químicos
sean sean este inventado para poder
describirlo muy bien es que vamos a
hacer lo paso por paso primero vamos a
poner nuevamente nuestros tres carbonos
nuestros tres carbonos y vamos a poner
como cada uno de ellos tiene una
estructura digamos en forma de tetraedro
cada uno de ellos tiene sus hidrógenos
pero vamos a poner estos dos últimos
hidrógenos en la misma línea muy bien
entonces cuando yo lo pinto de esta
forma con líneas digamos en cada uno de
los enlaces estoy
pensando que se mantienen digamos en una
misma superficie en un mismo plano ok si
los dibujos de esta forma se mantienen
es porque en su estructura
tridimensional se mantienen en el mismo
plano en el mismo plano perdón entonces
si dibujamos líneas quiere decir que el
enlace que los enlaces están en el plano
en un plano en el mismo plano digamos
como como lo podríamos ver por ejemplo
si si éstos están en el mismo plano
podríamos pensar que aquí tengo una hoja
de papel
digamos que aquí tengo una hoja de papel
que digamos que ahí está mi hoja de
papel
entonces como esta estructura se
mantiene en el mismo plano
podríamos pintar los tres carbonos aquí
los tres carbonos vamos a hacer un
poquito más amplio los 3 carbonos aquí y
los hidrógenos también se encuentran en
este mismo plano digamos en esta misma
hoja de papel muy bien ahora lo que
sabemos o lo que podríamos ver es qué
pasa con los otros hidrógenos por
ejemplo uno de ellos
bueno fijémonos por ejemplo en este
hidrógeno en particular si queremos que
este carbono con todos sus enlaces tenga
aún un arreglo en forma de tetraedro y
estos dos ya están en el mismo plano
quiere decir que este hidrógeno tiene
que salir del plano y eso lo vamos a
representar con una cuña muy bien vamos
a poner una cuña y la rellenamos si es
que este hidrógeno o esta este átomo o
lo que sea que estemos poniendo aquí
sale de nuestra hoja de papel se sale de
nuestra superficie en dos dimensiones
entonces la cuña corresponde a que el
enlace el enlace está frente a la hoja
de papel por ejemplo si nosotros
estuviéramos viendo desde aquí digamos
que éste es es mi ojo verdad aquí
estamos viendo entonces la cuña
representa a que este hidrógeno está
saltándose de la hoja de papel muy bien
ahora bien cuál sería la contraparte si
nosotros pensamos ahora en este
hidrógeno
entonces ese hidrógeno se encuentra por
debajo de la hoja de papel y eso lo
ponemos con una línea punteada que en
realidad no es tan punteada sino la
ponemos como con guiones ok pero vamos a
llamarle punteada entonces el enlace
viene digamos por atrás de nuestra de
nuestro de nuestra hoja y sale por abajo
ok entonces la línea punteada la línea
punteada
corresponde a que el enlace se encuentra
detrás de nuestra hoja de papel y ya con
esto uno podría completar todos los
enlaces posibles en este en este en esta
molécula que es el propano verdad por
ejemplo aquí ya tenemos estos dos
enlaces nuevamente uno de los hidrógenos
uno de los hidrógenos tiene que saltar
por arriba
de hecho déjenme ponerlo con el mismo
color que tenía uno de los hidrógenos
salta por arriba de la hoja verdad para
tener ese arreglo tridimensional en
forma de tres de tetra hidro y el otro
tiene que irse por detrás
ok entonces aquí bueno ya sabemos lo que
representa con nuestra hoja de papel y
con este último carbono nuevamente pues
tendremos uno que sale uno que sale
fuera de la hoja de papel y uno que está
por detrás muy bien entonces con esto tú
ya puedes más o menos imaginarte cuál es
el patrón que estamos siguiendo aquí
estamos viendo este patrón en donde
tenemos dos enlaces dos enlaces en cada
uno de estos carbonos tenemos dos
enlaces que están o que tienen
hibridación sp3 verdad entonces siempre
vamos a tener este arreglo en donde
tenemos dos enlaces digamos en línea
uno sería una una cuña y otro sería
punteada cuando tenemos los carbonos y
con hibridación sp3 vamos a ver un
ejemplo mucho más complicado ahí tenemos
esta es la estructura
la penicilina ok como puedes ver aquí
tenemos también algunas cuñas algunas
líneas punteadas así que estamos
presentando esta molécula vamos a ver
que como podríamos
describió cómo podríamos describir un
poco más esta molécula ok entonces no sé
por ejemplo vamos a enfocarnos en este
hidrógeno del perdón este carbono de
aquí aunque entonces este carbono de
aquí tiene tres enlaces tiene una cuña y
dos enlaces lineales entonces por lo que
vimos como este carbono siempre tiende a
ser ésta tiene hibridación sp3
entonces le corresponde una vamos a
ponerlo con otro color que se vea le
corresponde una línea punteada con la
molécula que le falta que es un
hidrógeno vamos a enfocarnos ahora en
este de aquí que entonces nuevamente
éste tiene tres moléculas y ya tiene una
cuña verdad está uniéndose a éste
y azufre con una cuña quiere decir que
el hidrógeno que le falta está por
debajo de la hoja de papel verdad muy
bien vamos a ver en que otro podríamos
enfocarnos por ejemplo enfoquémonos
ahora en este este carbono pues ya tiene
cuatro enlaces verdad y aquí se ve sus
dos enlaces lineales una cuña y un
apunte a la verdad y por lo tanto este
está unido a un carbono más lo mismo acá
verdad estos son carbonos vamos a ver
este es un carbono este es otro carbono
tiene dos enlaces lineales tiene una
línea punteada entonces le corresponde
un una cuña verdad le toca una cuña aquí
uniéndose a un hidrógeno veamos qué que
otra cosa podríamos ver este también es
un carbono este de aquí es un carbono y
ya tiene cuatro enlaces verdad cuatro
enlaces tiene un oxígeno
oxígeno y una línea punteada entonces ya
no necesita más digamos este también es
un carbono ya tiene sus cuatro enlaces
en fin así podríamos hacer el análisis
de todas las uniones digamos en su
estructura tridimensional simplemente de
observar cuáles son cuñas y cuáles son
punteadas vamos a ver si podemos ahora
contar todos los átomos que esta
molécula tiene así que digamos aquí
tenemos algunos carbonos aquí tenemos
carbono carbono cada uno de estos
vértices de este el hexágono es un
carbono verdad aquí tenemos un carbono
otro carbono aquí tenemos unido a un
nitrógeno ya vimos que este es carbono
carbono este también es un carbono
carbono carbono carbono carbono carbono
entonces vamos a contar cuántos carbonos
tenemos en realidad tenemos aquí 6 de
este hexágono 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
carbonos entonces vamos a tratar de dar
la fórmula molecular de ésta
la sustancia la penicilina ok tenemos 16
carbon os vamos a contar cuántos
hidrógenos entonces veamos que en estos
carbonos tenemos 3 enlaces entonces le
corresponde un hidrógeno a cada uno de
ellos verdad un hidrógeno excepto a este
último que ya tiene sus 4 enlaces
entonces nos saltamos a este y éste
tiene dos enlaces por lo tanto le faltan
otros dos hidrógenos y ahorita no vamos
a enfocarnos en sí tienen cuña o si
tienen línea punteada solo estamos
haciendo el conteo de hidrógenos aquí ya
tenemos cuatro enlaces que se conectan
con este carbono aquí está un hidrógeno
otro hidrógeno aquí ya no necesitamos
más ya no necesitamos más aquí estaba
este hidrógeno
muy bien aquí tenemos otro hidrógeno y
ahora aquí hay que tener cuidado estos
carbonos deben estar unidos a otros tres
hidrógenos a otros tres hidrógenos
verdad porque solo tienen un enlace
simple aquí
entonces aquí hay que juntarlo con estos
tres hidrógenos son entonces cuantos
tenemos tenemos 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 y me parece que falta
alguno
vamos a hacer de nuevo las cuentas son 5
aquí 6 7 8 9 10 5 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 claro ahí están los 18 hidrógenos
ahora cuántos nitrógenos tenemos cuántos
nitrógenos tenemos pues en realidad sólo
tenemos este y este así que tenemos 2
nitrógenos y tenemos 4 oxígenos verdad 1
2 3 4 oxígenos y simplemente nos falta
agregar este azufre así que tenemos un
único azufre y esta es la fórmula
molecular de esta penicilina entonces
espero que haya quedado un poco más
claro de cómo se representan las
estructuras tridimensionales de las
moléculas a partir de su estructura
enlace línea verdad y por supuesto aquí
por ejemplo podríamos notar que este
carbono ésta tiene una hibridación sp2
entonces esta estructura digamos
triangular está muy bien dibujada con
líneas porque se mantienen en el mismo
plano verdad lo mismo podríamos
pensar de cada uno de estos carbonos que
tienen una hibridación sp2 verdad
entonces bueno no no vamos a usar
siempre las cuñas y las líneas punteadas
para para todos los casos de hecho no no
no siempre se usan las cuñas y las
líneas punteadas para los carbonos con
hibridación sp3 de hecho estudiaremos en
vídeos futuros cuando si se usan y
cuando tienden a no usarse